[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur france 3 la
chaîne des municipales avant le deuxième
tour des élections le 28 juin
on se retrouve chaque soir à 18 heures
avec des débats avec les candidats des
principales villes de franche-comté
encore en lice avec ce soir une qu'un
kangoo l'air il n'y en a que douze dans
toute la france dont une chez nous en
franche comté dans le pays de
montbéliard il s'agit de mandeure ils
étaient cinq candidats au premier tour
ils seront cinq candidats au second tour
ils sont tous les cinq sur notre plateau
un plateau qu'il nous a fallu aménager
de manière particulière vous le voyez
pour respecter le protocole sanitaire je
vous présente donc ses cinq candidats
d'abord jean pierre ok 74 ans divers
droite vous êtes le maire sortant
demandeur vous avez conquis la mairie il
y a 6 ans en battant joseph tyrode aux
affaires pendant 27 ans lui vous l'avez
battu de 19 voix également sur ce
plateau patrick allain divers gauche 55
ans vous avez été adjoint aux travaux
sous joseph tyrode pendant deux mandats
sandra ramalho 44 ans élue en 2014 sur
la liste de jean-pierre ok vous partez
en dissidence
julien ceccarelli 31 ans vous êtes
adjoint au maire sortant vous êtes aussi
vous partie en dissidence et enfin
stéphane botz gora 41 noms divers gauche
c'est votre première campagne électorale
bonjour à tous les cinq
je précise qu'en raison de cette config
à des configurations particulières du
plateau vos places ont été tirés au sort
avant de vous donner la parole je vous
propose de revoir les résultats du
premier tour jean-pierre hockey était
arrivée en tête avec 33,8 % 2e patrick
allain 27,7 il ya 87 voix d'écart entre
les deux premiers suivent sans bras
ramalho et julien ceccarelli enregistré
je le précise tous les deux ans liste
divers en préfecture et stéphane peu de
gora vous avez tous franchi la barre des
10% qualificative pour le second tour
vous allez tous donc
vous présentez pour ce deuxième tour
alors le tirage au sort a désigné
patrick allain pour commencer ce premier
tour de table
monsieur alain pouvait nous pouvez vous
nous dire qui vous êtes et pourquoi vous
êtes candidat à cette municipale
demandeur donc je suis candidat à
l'élection municipale avec mon équipe
écoute et répond d'agir pour mandeure
2020 afin de mettre en oeuvre notre
programme avec la population de redonner
à la ville demandeur toute
l'attractivité qu'elle mérite au sein de
la communauté d'agglomération du pays de
montbéliard sépare d'ailleurs sur cette
thématique de travail que nous avons
rédigé ce programme concernant la
prévention sécurité l'environnement le
tourisme les associations les commerces
et artisans l'urbanisme les travaux
enfance jeunesse et scolaires centres
d'action sociale et les finances merci
monsieur alain sandra ramalho pourquoi
êtes-vous candidate à la mairie
demandeurs bonjour donc je suis sans
drame à l'eau je suis marié j'ai trois
enfants je suis préparatrice en
pharmacie et je me présente aujourd'hui
sur une liste apolitique aux municipales
car mon idée de la gestion d'une ville
diffère complètement de ce que j'ai pu
connaître pendant ces six années
j'espère que les décisions seront prises
avec une équipe et pas seulement qu'ils
tiennent qu'à une seule personne voire
un petit groupe de personnes
une équipe qui va mener des actions sur
le terrain on doit être à l'écouté de la
population et on essaiera bien sûr de
n'oublier personne
mon équipe et moi et moi même ouf
représente le changement pour cette
compagnie merci madame ramalho julien
ceccarelli pourquoi êtes vous candidat
julien ceccarelli 31 ans père de deux
enfants de trois et un an
diplômé de la faculté d'histoire de
besançon je me présente enfin nous nous
présentons d'abord dans l'idée de
changer les choses et de change évoluer
mandeure et je voulais profiter de ce
moment de présentation pour avoir un mot
et une pensée pour les proches des
familles qui ont pu disparaître pendant
cette crise et aussi aux personnes
malades qui je souhaite un bon
rétablissement et également tous les
personnels qui ont été mobilisés pendant
cette crise et qui ont rendu possible la
vie sur mandeure et en france
merci julien ceccarelli stéphane
bourgault rare même question pourquoi
êtes vous candidat alors bonjour à tous
merci de nous avoir accueillis pour ce
débat pour mandeure donc je suis
candidat pour un nouvel élan pour
mandeure une liste de simples citoyens
nous sommes pas des professionnels de la
politique et nous comptons proposer aux
habitants demandeurs à nouveau projet
politique
une nouvelle façon de faire basé sur la
démocratie participative
parce que nous on fait en tant
qu'habitant nous avons constaté en
réalité on n'avait pas beaucoup de
pouvoir dans la commune quand bien même
même si on ne veut pas ça veut dire il
ya des gens énormément du roman dire
qu'ils souhaitent s'investir
on leur donne pas la possibilité de le
faire et nous nous proposons justement
de donner à tout le monde
à chacun la possibilité de le faire s
adresser à tous les acteurs locaux
merci stéphane botz gora et enfin
jean-pierre ok pourquoi êtes vous
candidat pour un second mandat
candidat sur un second mandat pour la
bonne et simple raison c'est que au
départ nous avions un projet commun en
2014 que nous avons rempli dans sa
totalité
certes il y a eu des retards dole par
exemple dans les travaux mais les
projets 1,8 est maintenu pourquoi je
leur présente les biens avec mon équipe
tout simplement parce que il faut
nécessairement que on poursuivre notre
action qui avait été déterminant 2014 et
qui va et qui sera amendée en plus 7
durant cette mandature alors on va
rentrer dans le détail de vos programmes
aux uns et aux autres dans un instant
mais d'abord nous sommes allés
interroger il ya quelques jours
quelques-uns des 4900 mandubien les
habitants de mandeure ils ont dit à
maxime haut niveau et rémy poireau ce
qu'ils attendaient du futur maire on les
écoute qui faussent gibelin que la ville
du dynamisme des séries comme anders et
comme ac cannes et c'est vrai que
faurecia qui va bientôt partir dans
quelle salle est un peu fait un peu
moche pour la ville et j'aimerais bien
que le super u tous les petits commerces
qui ferment pas c'est qu'on prévu de
fermer déjà moi je suis plus pour faire
participer les gens en fait donc demandé
l'avis des gens et puis voir ma quelles
sont leurs soucis et chacun après ça ce
vote ça ce qu'on peut faire basso j'ai
passé des référendum au niveau des
communes mais que chacun donne son avis
moi ce que j'attends c'est une n'est pas
que pour les anciens qui est pour les
gamins pour les jeunes pour une autre
âge ça bouge un peu plus s'ils roulent
moins vite sur tout ça et puis des
trottoirs aussi ça pour être pas mal
mais ça il ya un manque
à oui oui quand on va chercher les
enfants à l'école y en a pas quand on y
va à pied tout ça ou avec la poussette
c'est pas pratique du tout le départ de
faurecia la fermeture des commerces la
vie sociale on va parler de tout cela
mais d'abord la sécurité routière
problématique très concrètes pour les
habitants de mandeure villes traversées
sur près de 4,4 km par une
départementale
alors quelles sont vos propositions aux
uns et aux autres pour sécuriser cet axe
accidentogène monsieur pas de boire on
commence avec vous la solution je compte
le monde sait que ça
la mairie qui la détient ces deux
départements mais par contre il faut
absolument que nous adressons à toute la
commune afin de repenser cette voie
parce que c'est comme une autoroute
c'est très dangereux c'est pas beau et
pour ceux qui sont pas demandeur qui
sont que de passage
honnêtement vous passez dans cette ville
il se passerait il n'ya pas s'entremêler
rien du tout donc il faut repenser cette
route là sécurisé en l'aménageant
autrement notamment sur les coins où il
ya des commerces
je pense à la place de la république je
pense à l'entrée de beaulieu est là il
faut créer des endroits piétonnier
sécurisé pour que déjà les commerces
puissent avoir des clients parce que
c'est difficile de se garer et secundo
pour que tout le monde soit en sécurité
sandra ramalho oui alors moi tout
d'abord au niveau sécurité nous avons
réfléchi parce que au niveau de la
police municipale c'est quand même on va
revenir à la sécurité en général
j'aimerais vous entendre sur la sécurité
routière alors sur la sécurité routière
mais comme l'a dit une dame précédemment
effectivement il y a des trottoirs qui
faudrait penser
et comme je rejoins aussi un petit peu
les idées de monsieur pouls de gora il
ya quand même un gros aménagements à
faire sur cette aire d après il faut
savoir aussi que ça un coup voir ce
qu'il est possible de faire au niveau
financier et sur le terrain évidemment
je viens ceccarelli à la sécurité des
automobilistes et des piétons
voilà et de toute façon déjà il faut
partir du principe parler en vérité à la
population en leur disant qu'il n'y a
pas de solution miracle premièrement
quand on met des zones 30 ou con ou
qu'on sécurise certains secteurs si les
automobilistes n'ont pas envie de
respecter la vitesse il ne la
respecteront pas maintenant pour ce qui
est de la départementale c'est un projet
qui va dépasser quand même au moins dix
millions d'euros c'est quand même énorme
donc il faut travailler que le
département et les habitants il faut
végétalisée cette départementale et puis
surtout il faut refondre le réseau
secondaire parce que c'est le réseau
secondaire cas vraiment vraiment très
très accidentogène patrick allain
concernant la r d effectivement la
problématique
il faut requalifier cette cette route
par des moyens physiques surtout faire
un retraçage principalement pour la
piste cyclabe c'est une piste cyclable
qui est prise en même temps sur la voie
avoir des contrôles de vitesse je pense
par les forces de l'ordre
de temps en temps afin de marquer les
choses que les gens s'aperçoivent que la
police est sur place et que là il y aura
certainement des verbalisations suite à
des excès de vitesse
la présence de la police donc sur cette
voie pas en permanence en tout cas sur
des périodes ce qui permettrait à la
population d'être aussi rassuré de cette
présence jean pierre roquet sur cette
départementale 437 effectivement vous
reconnaissez que c'est accidentogène
c'est accidentogène dans certains
secteurs c'est vrai que nous avons quand
même une départementale qui comporte
quatre lignes droites
catherine droite qui amène à rouler vite
pour certains
malgré qu'elle soit disons qu'il y ait
des feux sur tout son parcours une
partie de son parcours
cela n'empêche que ça roule très vite
oui c'est accidentogène alors ça c'est
un constat
c'est les solutions à la solution qu'on
envisage d'ailleurs c'est en liaison
avec le département puisque c'est un
ouvrage du département de recalibrer de
recalibrer la voirie pour justement
inciter les gens roulent moins vite 710
réduire la dimension des vous d'accord
moi large moins larges pour permettre à
la fois et du stationnement dans
certains secteurs et les pistes une
piste cyclable pour éviter qu'elle ne
soit sur la départementale c'est vrai
que ce nécessite des travaux de longue
haleine des gens nés en travaux pour les
réseaux c'est vrai que ça viendra après
mais pour la sécurité c'est essentiel
que ce soit comme ça
après les contrôles qu'il y aura requis
peuvent être exécutés là dessus ça c'est
du courant sandra ramalho vous l'avez
abordé sécurité route et en sécurité
vous méfier là
transition avant l'heure mandeure
dispose de quatre postes de policiers
municipaux qui je le précise sont armés
il ya une vingtaine de caméras de
vidéosurveillance est-ce que c'est
suffisant est-ce que c'est trop quelles
sont vos propositions en la matière
alors trop je ne sais pas toujours est
il qu'aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que
deux agents donc forcément ça manque sur
la commune donc il faudra penser à faire
un recrutement car c'est vraiment
nécessaire parce qu'après il y aura ça
va permettre une plus grande amplitude
horaire pour qu'il puisse travailler sur
sur la ville tout simplement parce que
on les voyait beaucoup au début
puisqu'il était bien 4 est alors
d'aujourd'hui ils sont plus que deux
donc on ne les voit plus mais c'est quoi
le problème mandeure et pas assez
attractif pour un policier municipal
comme pour d'autres professions c'est un
brin d'ordre général pourquoi il ya que
moi je pense qu'il ya un peu de tout
tout simplement après
si vous voulez avec ses caméras il faut
aussi d optimiser dans le sens où si les
agents sont sur les caméras ils peuvent
pas être sur le terrain
donc effectivement ça manque c'est un
manque de 2,2 personnes et donc nous
avions pensé avec mon équipe à soulager
un petit peu cette police municipale en
créant une brigade verte qui ferait du
préventif et qui pourraient pour
justement un peut intervenir soulager
sans pouvoir autant verbalisé parce que
ce ne sera pas forcément des personnes
assermentées ça sera par exemple de
personnes des agents du de l'espace
lergue les personnes qui seraient
intéressées
et puis ce qui serait intéressant aussi
c'est que ben on va rentrer aussi dans
la polyvalence des agents
patrick allard je vous ai vu réagir non
simplement non je voulais être en phase
avec sodi son drame à l'eau dans le sens
oui aujourd'hui on a une garde
communautaire qui a été créée il ya pas
si longtemps sur le pm a donc pays de
montbéliard agglomération c'est
l'inversé les notaires et bien mais je
crois qu'on les a pas sur la charte pour
mandeure puisqu'il ya eu à une chose qui
est qui a été il y avait en fait une
charte où il devait agir par agir donc
nous ne les a pas encore chez nous
aujourd'hui
mais c'est comme les anciens gardes
champêtres même beaucoup mieux équipés
et armés d'ailleurs qui font la police
des forêts mais qui font si la police de
l'environnement qui est intéressant
aussi puisque pendant cette campagne
qu'on a eus j'ai eu beaucoup de
personnes qui m'ont dit que tout ce qui
était déchets ou ont retrouvé des
déchets dans la rue tout ça donc on sait
pas tord à qui s'adresser ces gens de de
police peuvent intervenir
verbaliser remonter les infos mer
donc c'est bien que la collaboration
entre la police la gendarmerie police
municipale gendarmerie et les gardes
communautaire je trouve que c'est un bon
trio de sécurité jean-pierre roquet sur
ces postes de policiers municipaux non
pourvus vous n'êtes qu'à la moitié des
effectifs est ce que c'est un handicap
pour votre ville
c'est un handicap certes mais il faut
dire aussi une chose c'est que dans la
fonction publique les gens mute vont
dans d'autres services quand vie sourit
trouvent un intérêt pour y aller donc
c'est tout à fait normal que ces agents
se déplacent maintenant la difficulté
qu'il y assez que s'il y a beaucoup
d'agents en formation mais pas forcément
des agents qui viennent dans des
communes comme la nôtre on a des agents
de police missionnaire vous si vous êtes
aimée pour un deuxième mandat
qu'est ce que vous faites en termes de
sécurité qu'à l'heure actuelle selon
clay recrutement de deux agents de
police municipale
donc ça va ça va se dérouler dans les
jours qui viennent et 4 c'est suffisant
ou vous voulez augmenter l'is est déjà
pas mal d'accord 4 c'est déjà pas mal si
on peut faire des rotations du riz
nocturne
après c'est sûr que c'est une question
d'organisation
stéphane pas de gare à vos propositions
en matière de sécurité pour mon heure
alors pour la sécurité notamment de la
police à notre sens la sécurité c
une trêve objective régaliennes je vois
pas la police venir à mandeure pour agir
qu'il n'y a pas énormément de violence à
mandeure donc on n'est plus sûr d asi
bilité de la prévention de la sécurité
routière
donc soyons clairs si vous arrivez aux
affaires vous supprimez la police
municipale évidemment non parce que je
parle et quand vous dites que ses
fonctions régaliennes je préfère le mans
dans l'appartement de la sécurité
on parle de violence tout ça au niveau
des polices municipales je la vois pas
que je la conçois pas comme ça il ya des
incivilités il ya de la sécurité pour
les enfants autour des écoles tout cela
il faut il faut des personnes donc pour
pour le surveiller et donc les agents
municipaux qui sont actuellement au
nombre de 2 s'est largement pas
suffisant notamment pour agir le jour et
la nuit
et donc nous pensons que en ce qui
concerne la sécurité municipale
il faudrait envisager de mutualiser les
moyens avec les communes voisines
ce que quelque part on peut s'entendre
notamment avec valentine et mater pour
avoir des effectifs plus conséquents et
qui pourrait tourner beaucoup plus je
viens c'est qu'à ceccarelli sur la
sécurité alors la sécurité avec la
police municipale puisque c'est le thème
principal dans le fond c'est la
municipale la municipale avait quatre
effective quand nous sommes arrivés en
2014-2015 c'était une promesse de
campagne
j'ai bien entendu monsieur le maire qui
nous dit que les agents minutes qu'il y
à des déplacements mais je crois aussi
qu'il ya un problème de recrutement sur
la commune de mandeure et puis il ya un
manque de respect aussi parfois de
certains élus envers certains agents
donc ça crée des conflits et des
tensions qui font que les agents parfois
aussi envie de partir de la commune
maintenant pour ce qui est de la
municipale ils ne sont que 2 donc
évidemment vous avez rappelé qu'il y
avait 4 km de départementales ce qui
fait d'eux une chose impossible à gérer
de jour ou de nuit
donc il faut absolument passer à 4 il
faut qu'on m'a dit monsieur le maire que
on est une patrouille qui puisse
s'effectuer la nuit et ensuite il faut
collaborer activement comme on le fait
plutôt déjà pas mal avec
la vidéosurveillance la gendarmerie et
puis pourquoi pas la brigade champêtre
pma puisque nous avons un vendeur la
plus grande forêt de pays de montbéliard
agglomération
alors on l'a entendu tout à l'heure avec
le micro trottoir à mandeure faurecia va
quitter mandeure pour rejoindre un autre
site sur l'agglomération de montbéliard
peugeot motocycles que tout le monde
appelle chez vous ou encore pmtc n'est
pas au mieux de sa forme
quelles sont les marges de manoeuvre
d'un maire face aux difficultés
économiques des entreprises de sa
commune jean-pierre roquet est ce que
finalement on n'est pas démuni parfois
quand on est maire face à des décisions
de grosses entreprises comme celle là
tout à fait dire qu on est démuni
c'est peut-être un gros mot un grand mot
il faut pas oublier quand même que
l'industrie dépend aussi de
l'agglomération et que dans l'ensemble
tout ce qui est industriel et quand même
traité par l'agglomération et qu'à
partir de là une décision d'une
entreprise telle que faurecia comme de
n'importe quelle entreprise dès
l'instant où elle a décidé de partir
pour des raisons qui sont justifiées eh
bien elle partira quoi qu'on en fasse
pour qu'on dise elle partira mais c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait un prêt du coup la
question on les lui sont donc comment on
qualifie le site comment on attire
d'autres entreprises
si vous voulez avec faurecia a et b et
l'agglomération
quand même travaillé donc celui qu'on
met plus de trois ans qu'on travaille
avec eux pour trouver des solutions
parce que c'est vrai que pour faurecia
c'est une situation qui n'est plus
tenable à l'heure actuelle sur le plan
industriel sur le plan des dés
délais d'approvisionnement donc il est
bien évident que faurecia a envisagé de
partie depuis trois ans on négocie avec
eux depuis trois ans pm l'agglomération
va reprendre les bâtiments pour les
réaménager pour en faire un site
toujours un site industriel faut pas
oublier que nous sommes nous avons des
entreprises à mettre dedans déjà il y
aura il y aura des entreprises dans
l'immédiat p faurecia parts dans 3 ans
donc on a encore trois ans pour faire et
d'une nouvelle cité le faire venir des
entreprises patrick allard est ce que
quand vous entendez jean-pierre ok vous
êtes rassurés je suis rassuré dans le
sens où il dit que pas qu'il dit que
dans trois ans faut aussi à main fermée
mais qu' il risque d'y avoir un
potentiel pour pouvoir ré équiper ces
zones
en commerce ou chose comme ça
industriels c'est en effet le site
industries sur le site industriel
par contre on a déjà une partie de
faurecia qui est partie sûrement deux
heures quarante quatre mille mètres
carrés qui sont aujourd'hui en friche
donc dont nous notre équipe on a un
projet dessus et surtout pas là la
projet d'une maison seniors qui est je
crois dans les cordes aujourd'hui de
vous monsieur le maire et devaient y mas
pour nous pour notre équipe
nous voyons pas cette maison à cet
endroit nous la verrons mieux en
arrière-plan de la ville sur l'ancienne
église sainte thérèse qui est un terrain
communal qui n'est pas un terrain pma
qui je pense pour les seniors seraient
plus paisible
premièrement faut dépolluer le site de
faurecia
deuxièmement il y aura toujours un
trafic de camions de choses comme ça ça
reste quand même un milieu industriel je
pense pas qu'à maison seniors soit la
mieux placée à cet endroit
moi je pense que une bonne étude fait
que cette maison pour être plus
attractif pour les seniors dans un
endroit paisible et de proximité
stéphane pagora sur cette attractivité
industriels et l'avenir industriel de et
économique demandeurs exactement donc
fort et ça va partir c'est acté donc
c'est je crois l'agglomération qui
reprend site de ce que j'ai compris et
donc la commune à part collaborer avec
pma sur le futur de ce site
honnêtement je peux pas moi
personnellement vous dire aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on préfère dessus parce que
à la nuit je dirais presque la mairie
n'a pas la main dessus
par contre la désindustrialisation dans
son ensemble il faut y réfléchir à
mandeure parce qu'on a encore de belles
industrie la papeterie à pmtc on encore
des industries qui sont là et donc il
faut essayer déjà qu'elle reste même si
j'ai bien compris qu'on n'avait pas le
pouvoir non plus deux
de les maintenir en place parce qu'ils
ont leur propre décision mais il faut
aussi réfléchir à un nouvel avenir une
nouvelle vision pour la commune parce
qu'il n'ya pas que les industries à
mandeure et avant tout autre en tant
qu'habitant c'est comme ça qu'on le
ressent un énorme potentiel
environnemental et touristique
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut pour un
noir pour nous - c'est là dessus qu'il
faut qu'il faut tabler parce que
l'environnement
c'est formidable pour tous les habitants
de mandeure donc il faut absolument
appuyer nos projets là dessus et
pourquoi pas de venir à lui
incontournable dans l'agglomération haut
niveau au niveau tourisme on y reviendra
julien ceccarelli sur l'économie alors
l'économie donc faurecia va partir il
nous reste bmtc avec 485 salariés il
nous reste fuji autotech la papeterie
demandeurs et puis il faut pas aussi
qu'on oublie parce qu'on a tendance à
toujours parler du tissu industriel à
mandeure puisqu'il a beaucoup marqué
notre époque depuis les années 1980 le
jeu mais il faut pas qu'on oublie aussi
tout ce qui est commerçants artisans tpe
pme l'un quand on parle de moins de 250
salariés
on passe tout de suite sur ces stades là
il faut absolument que la commune
d'abord soit présente
c'est à dire que moi pendant ce mandat
j'ai vu par exemple des manifestations
pour les 120 ans de peugeot il ya 120
personnes qui ont été licenciées et je
n'ai pas vu monsieur le maire en train
de manifester avec les gens en bas de
l'immeuble de peugeot des bureaux de jo
et ça je le regrette parce que le maire
déjà il doit être là il doit être
présent physiquement pour comprendre ce
qui se passe exactement et entendre les
salariés quand ils sont dans dans un
gros souci comme comme le licenciement
ensuite pour ce qui est faurecia sait
très bien que pma prennent la main sur
le site mais la commune demandeur ne
doit pas laisser faire pma comme elle
veut pma doit aussi prendre en
considération les administrés de la
commune demandeur on rentre exactement
dans la même situation que le théâtre
romain demandeurs avec un pavillon ça
doit être avec un avis consultatif la
population doit être consulté et puis
sur beaulieu surtout il faut redynamiser
la partie commerciale
sandra mallon je vous entendez donné
quitus à votre voisin à votre ex
compagnon de la majorité
alors oui avec tout ce que je viens
d'entendre fasse un petit sourire quoi
je me dis effectivement ça tout se
rejoint on a beaucoup d'idées
le souci c'est que vous faites tous le
même constat
on pourrait se demander de l'extérieur
ce qui vous sépare à part des questions
de personnes c'est que en fait voilà
c'est aujourd'hui voilà moi ce que je
trouve malheureux c'est que m'a déjà
cessé quand même pma qui a fait que
forestier et part sur etupes les dates
qu'on m'a communiqué ne ressent pas
celle que monsieur hockey a annoncé
donc ce serait plus prévu pour 2021 donc
ça fait beaucoup plus proche
et sur ce site effectivement il y aura
la peau des pollutions à faire il y aura
beaucoup de choses à faire
ça a un coût donc maintenant que
l'intervention de pma effectivement
c'est bien mais aussi c'est aussi qu'ils
nous ont mis un petit peu dans la panade
parce que ben si faurecia ce moment
c'est un petit peu grâce aussi à pma
maintenant que pma et des idées et qu'on
travaille en collaboration avec eux oui
mais effectivement on ne doit pas
laisser pma prendre la main sur tout ce
qui appartient à mandeure comme le
théâtre gallo romain la gestion de la
salle des sports
eugène courvoisier le camping etc il
faut il faut vraiment que y ait un
travail de ensemble qui doit être fait
pour justement essayer d'apporter une
amélioration du quotidien des habitants
demandeurs alors justement le quotidien
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse un rapide
tour de table l'attractivité pour la vie
quotidienne ça peut être les services à
la personne l'attractivité commerciale
les animations qu'est ce que vous
proposez
de ce point de vue là on peut rajouter
aussi l'offre de santé un tour de table
ont commencé avec vous monsieur gbagbo
aura alors pour l'attractivité
commerciale
nous avons les commerces on va dire
essentiels à la vie boulangerie
pharmacie
quoi faire exactement c'est pas ça qui
manque mais par contre on n'a aucune
diversité dans les commerces
donc notre idée nous c'est déjà
pérenniser les commerces qui sont à
mandeure parce que ça devient très
compliqué pour eux c'est un commerce
c'est qu'une entreprise s'est elle veut
rester c'est de l'argent fauqué des
clients or les clients à mandeure il y
en aura de moins en moins si on continue
comme ça on va pas se fâcher mondiale
est quand même sur le déclin on perd des
habitants
donc il faut retrouver notre activité
pour attirer les commerces et pour
attirer les commerces il faut qu'ils
aient des gens aux caisses des
consommateurs et pour faire venir les
consommateurs
il faut créer un environnement favorable
pour ça je viens ceccarelli vous êtes
d'accord avec le diagnostic posé par
havas voisin absolument en plus en tant
que professeur d'économie il a une
vision qui a un peu plus développé que
moi même si j'ai été diplômé aussi en
économie sociale mais il a tout à fait
compris que sur beaulieu on était en
train d'avoir justement ce qu'on disait
cette perte d'aspect commercial on a
encore eu une boutique a fermé il ya peu
de temps anciennement boucherie rosales
est un traiteur très connue très utilisé
par les habitants ça c'est le constat
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors lieu
alors en fait il faut re programmer le
cadre de vie de la commune la commune de
mandeure c'est un milieu industriel avec
la nature le tourisme le patrimoine
et puis tous les services à la personne
donc si on arrive dans le cadre d'une
maison médicale à faire revenir des
praticiens par exemple en arabe on aura
une meilleure offre de santé mais on
peut aussi pour pour suivre un petit peu
sur l'histoire du tourisme et bien
envisager autre chose que ce qui se
passe actuellement et puis développer le
tourisme et le patrimoine tout en le
gardant quand même de façon vertige pu
dire ça touche pas à tourisme industriel
ordonnerait la parole sur le tourisme
ont fini ce tour de table sur le
commerce et la réactivité sur le
commerce il faut donner de
l'attractivité aux commerçants mais une
dynamique locale il faut que nous élus
nous soyons sous le terrain que nous
verrons comptions que nous fassions des
réunions avec les commerçants qui est à
nouveau un président des commerçants
pourquoi pas l'association qui leur
verse un kick
soit remise en place afin de bain comme
une réunion publique demandée il est pro
la problématique qui se passe et ensuite
faire des échanges ensuite faire des
propositions je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
besoin le plus utile pour la population
c'est que l'élu local doit contacter la
population pour discuter avec des futurs
projets alors moi ça rien exactement ce
que je disais tout à l'heure qu'il faut
encore des convergences entre vous très
bien c'est qu'on en fait il faut
vraiment qu'on soit sur le terrain après
je tiens juste ça à faire également une
petite parenthèse donc on parle de tout
ça il faut savoir quand même que nous
avons un super u que il a été quand même
menacé par l'installation d'un lidl à
valentigney et là je suis désolé oui et
qui a menacé quand même super u il faut
savoir aussi qu'on a une population déjà
d'un certain âge donc si nous n'avons
plus de super u il faut vraiment qu'on
se le préserve qu'on préserve également
les autres petits commerces et nous
donne avec notre équipe nous avons
travaillé sur le sujet et nous pensent
ou travaillent en collaboration avec bg
e pour faire du recrutement des
collections jean pierre roquet
rapidement s'il vous plaît ce que j'ai
entendu en creux c'est que les élus
c'est vous 4-2 aux affaires donc voilà
n'était pas forcément assez présent
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
critiques à être présent au lait on
n'est pas tous les jours dans les
commerces
il est évident que ni l'une pas que
visiter les commerces
cela étant les six des commerces
disparaissent c'est d'une part de vous
couper monsieur ok mais ça a été aussi
la nôtre campagne de 2014
on s'est quand même avancé en disant
qu'on sera beaucoup sur le terrain nous
sommes quand même 21 plus l'opposition
que nous sommes beaucoup d'élus donc on
peut et chaque personne fait à chaque
élu adjoint à des commissions donc on
peut aller sur le terrain est discutée
je suis désolé toute façon ils se
pensent cachant derrière un bureau qu'on
va faire avancer les choses nous étions
sur le terrain nous étions hier
sur le voilà c'est ça et c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il allait répondait optique
dont vous faites l'objet nation ce que
l'on entend par aller sur le terrain
lorsqu'on est dans comme tu dis derrière
d'un bureau est rarement derrière un
bureau
on s'occupe aussi des autres a fermé le
commerce est quelque chose d'important
on le sait mais ce qu'on sait aussi
c'est que si on n'a pas regardé le
nombre de commerces qui ont disparu sur
lander et qui ont été repris pour faire
des logements
c'est pas le c'est pas la mairie c'est
quand même bien les propriétaires qui
veulent changer qui veulent avoir un
rapport beaucoup plus importants
l'amérique une dans les boutiques
monsieur le maire au lieu de les laisser
partir ou alors attendre des boutiques
où il faut avoir les moyens nécessaires
ils ont repris quand même bénéficie
quand même de subventions que nous
n'avons pas nous certes mais quand même
quand on voit des rues entières
disparaître son commerce ce serait quand
même intéressant de garder au moins une
boutique parce que vous savez très bien
qu'il ya des indépendants qui
travaillent chez eux sur la commune et
qui ne demandent que ça d'avoir une
boutique à pignon sur rue et bien sûr on
le fait dans le cadre des charges on
leur fait un loyer adapter ce n'est pas
la question mais c'était juste réfléchir
à sa ronde je vous ai pas demandé de
racheter tout va quand on a eu et
trouver des solutions éventuellement au
niveau des fiscalités pour justement
attirer des personnes qui viennent bien
avoir une petite boutique ne serait-ce
qu'un réparateur de téléphone les
personnes âgées qui ont un téléphone
portable
je pense qu'ils seront bien contents
d'avoir le petit le petit monsieur avec
sa petite boutique qui oublié il faut
voilà c'est qu'une chose
encore faut-il avoir les locaux lorsque
les locaux ne nous appartiennent pas je
prends l'exemple la boucherie ammann
place de la république à fait
les locaux ne nous appartiennent pas on
ne peut pas les racheter le propriétaire
refuse comme il refuse je les ai essayé
de le rencontrer je les convoquer jamais
venu et ammann était prêt à ouvrir à
faire un traiteur malheureusement ça n'a
pas pu se faire tout simplement parce
que le propriétaire ne veut pas
alors ça va rester comme ça en ruines
jusqu'au moment où on va être obligé de
mettre une déclaration dessus et puis de
éventuellement de racheter ça c'est une
chose mais de raser puisque ça ne fait
non peu palace sur le plan patrimoine
je pense que sur les autres commerces
la boucherie rosales elle a été reprise
par des gens qui étaient incompétents et
qui à partir de là on fait couler la
boîte on est d'accord je suis désolé
c'est pas la mairie qui peut les
reprendre j'ai été voir le sous préfet
mais il n'est plus le lire vous arriver
parce que vous vous parler tout seul du
coup il n'est pas question de racheter
le commerce en faillite par exemple je
prends un exemple on a une maraîchère
bio qu installé sur la commune que des
difficultés financières on a fait une
cagnotte
elle s'est relevé de ses difficultés
financières vous étiez vous vous
monsieur le maire pour ces difficultés
là parce que d'ailleurs à la combe aux
ânes c'est un vrai boulot mais on agit
sur d'autres domaines faut pas l'oublier
vous agissez sur toute la commune
monsieur le maire dans ce dans ce cas
particulier on a du talent on agit sur
d'autres de dans d'autres patrick alain
comment vous regarder parce que là on a
assisté depuis 5 minutes à trois membres
de la même majorité en 2004 se déchire
et notamment sur la manière d'exercer le
pouvoir comment l'opposition voit ça je
le banc foncé clou c'est autre chose
mais mais effectivement je vois on voit
bien la dissidence là qui devrait pas
être même sort dans ce débat je trouve
qu'on est plutôt là pour discuter de nos
projets d'avenir
les uns les autres en fonction nous
liste pineau engagements que nous avons
pris mais il l'a dit aussi l'opposition
n'est pas les jeunes états unis parce
que vous avez aussi chacun des membres
de l'ancienne équipe
joseph tyrode dans vos listes je peux me
permettre nous sommes venus de position
nous n'appartenons pas au conseil
municipal actuel à l'averse de tout le
monde ici je le rappelle ne sommes pas
des professeurs de là je vous ai dit
rentrée de son équipier bon bref je
n'étais pas élu en 2014
attendez on laisse finir à monsieur pas
dehors voilà je rappelle juste qu'il
faut pas non plus à verser déroulent les
politiques c'est vous ce pas nous et
nous on est là pour les habitants et
nous ce qu'on propose c'est le pouvoir
des habitants avec une collaboration
avec eux les faire participer et ce qui
nous je vais vous et c'est notre liste
c'est parce qu'on a vu justement la
majorité actuelle et l'opposition
actuelle ce qui est passé à rouler ça
chacun on arrive au terme de ce débat je
vous laisse à chacun 40 secondes pour
conclure pour vous adresser aux
habitants demandeurs et les convaincre
de voter pour vous reprend l'ordre du
début d'émission patrick allain vous
avez la parole 40 secondes s'il vous
plaît à la conclusion de ce débat je
suis de passer le message mots du bien
au moins dû bienne ce deuxième tour des
élections municipales sera déterminant
le 28 juin venez voter pour notre liste
nous engageons dans les six ans à venir
de construire ensemble avec vous le
monde de demain
merci monsieur alain sandra ramalho
alors donc moi je dirai tout simplement
que nous avons survolé un petit peu tout
toutes les éventualités ce qui est
important de retenir c'est que nous
avons construit nous notre programme en
connaissance du budget donc on fait pas
dans la démagogie
on n'est pas prêt à tout pour être élu
et nous représentons le changement à
mandeure nous sommes l'alternative est
tout simplement je dirais que si comme
nous vous voulez ce changement voté avec
vous mandeure demain voter cendrars mal
an merci sandra ramalho julien
ceccarelli votre conclusion
j'aurais voulu parler tellement plus
longtemps de beaulieu mandeure c'est
dommage qu'on n'ait pas plus de temps
mais c'est déjà parfait merci encore
nous ne sommes pas
des hommes et des femmes politiques nous
sommes des citoyennes et des citoyens
engagés nous ne voulons pas être
étiqueté nous en avons assez de la
gauche et de la droite qui se bat depuis
plus de 35 ans sur la commune demandeur
qui ne tiennent pas compte de l'avis de
la population nous voulons une
démocratie participative et surtout
travaillé sur le référendum est consulté
la population le plus possible stéphane
botz gora votre conclusion
alors je vais rebondir sur la rumeur que
vous aviez fait par rapport aux idées
communes qu'on avait ensemble parce que
vous allez voir je m'adresse aujourd'hui
bien et le mandubien que les programmes
en réalité sont à 95% sensiblement les
mêmes
nous notre problème ce n'est pas le
programme c'est la façon de voir les
choses
ce qu'on propose nous puisqu'on après de
fusion au 1er tour entre trois listes
dont la nôtre ce que je propose une
fusion à 5 en réalité voilà exactement
si vous votez pour nous nous on s'engage
à demander aux autres candidats de nous
fournir des candidats pour les postes
d'adjoints parce que on n'a pas
travaillé les uns contre les autres
la division s'amène rien nous ce qu'on
veut c'est le patient dans le monde des
bisounours
aulas c'est la conclusion il conclut
comme il
il conclut comme il veut et enfin place
et enfin s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
jean-pierre ok votre conclusion vous
avez une quarantaine de secondes pour
conclure la conclusion pour moi c'est
que nous avons fait suivirent programme
pendant six ans et que ce programme nous
l'avons rénové nous avons ramené autre
chose dedans et je pense que ce
programme de 2020 à 2026 et bien c'est
le programme que nous proposons et que
je souhaite aussi bien entendu que les
conduisent bienne et mandubien s'y
intéressent et votent pour nous tout
simplement parce que nous avons encore
beaucoup de choses à faire beaucoup de
projets réalistes
merci à tous les cinq d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle que donc le
second tour c'est le dimanche 28 juin
cinq listes donc en compétition sur la
commune de mandeure c'est une des
douze communes de france à proposer
cette configuration merci donc à 19h à
18h50 même vous retrouver adrien gavazzi
pour l'information en région demain la
suite de nos débats avec les principales
villes de franche-comté encore en lice
demain 18 heures c'est saint-claude
jeudi valentigney on retrouvera dans le
pays de montbéliard après un détour par
le jura et puis enfin vendredi deux
communes salins les bains dans le jura
et babiller dans le territoire de
belfort
profitez bien de votre soirée france 3
la chaîne des municipales merci de nous
avoir suivis
[Musique]
on